[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Andrew in Nevada hey
guys I love listening to your show and
it's helped me give me a lot of comfort
in my life I've heard Dave says he gives
a 10 tithe and I do as well and believe
the same my question is will there ever
be a time when you wouldn't tithe in
order to get yourself out of a bad
financial situation I was in a situation
where it was hard to tithe and I'm just
curious as to what thoughts you guys
have I realize this is probably more of
a spiritual question than a money
question
um what do you think
I'm 100 sure that your tithe has nothing
to do with your salvation
I'm 100 sure from scripture that God
loves you if you tither if you don't
tithe exactly the same he's wildly crazy
about you the purpose of the tithe is
not to get a Boy Scout badge in heaven
that's not the purpose of the tithe
your father who's crazy about you says
hon the best way to live your life is
give a tenth of your income off the top
before you do anything
and I'll love you anyway whether you do
that or not but your father says stay
out of debt because the borrower is
slave to the lender your father says
don't build a tower without first
cutting the calls unless you get halfway
up and you're unable to finish and all
who see you begin to mock you and
this man began to build and was unable
to finish that's Jesus's words sang to a
budget
don't bill without a plan
don't build without a plan this is your
father none of these things affect his
love for you or your salvation
so Tyler don't tithe God still loves you
now if my dad who's crazy about me and
knows more than me says tithe a tithe
but it has nothing to do with earning
anything the my grace is taken care of
it's substantial
it's substantial it's taken care of so
you know it's way more crazy to answer
your question I tithe all the way into
bankruptcy court and all the way out but
it had nothing to do with I was scared
of God it had nothing to do with I was
trying to earn his favor it had to do
with apparently
you can live on ninety percent of
whatever if you're not making much and
you're having a hard time it's not it's
ten percent of not much
and so I did I tied all the way in all
the way out and it wasn't because I'm a
legalist and it wasn't because of that
it was because I I think it's the best
way to live just like I think staying
out of debt's the best way to live yeah
I I like to look at some of these um
quote unquote rules these scriptural
rules as
they're not this is the best way to live
your life they're not rude it's a gift
it's the best exactly so
um there's something about giving
there's something about a spirit of
gratitude that keeps your head your eyes
out of your navel and helps you look up
and see your neighbor it just changes
the way you you work your way through
life and there's something about meeting
people eye to eye hand to hand that
changes the way you your heart beats and
so I think this is much less a it is a
spiritual question more than a money
question but it's actually a
physiological question it's a
relationship question it's a way to do
life it's a way to do life and and your
father who
is The Great I Am who's standing there
five years from now knows where you're
going to be and they've stand there five
years ago and knows where you came from
at the same time not bound by time is is
saying son best way to live and so I'm
it's for me it's just like it's a it's
an Act of Faith at that point faith in
in that but it's not but if someone says
uh you can't you can't be blessed
because God because you're not tithing
not true yeah not true at all not true
can't find it in scripture oh you can
find scripture taken out of context to
point to that but um God is not God does
not need your money he's God if he
wanted your money he'd take it and
there'll be a greasy spot where you were
sitting he's God he doesn't need your
money
but he wants you to win he wants you to
have an abundant life